bonsoir c'est d'être avec nous comment
accueillez vous cette nouvelle
augmentation de 8 milliards d'euros au
budget de la santé n'est pas une bonne
chose mais derrière ça c'est assez
pervers puisqu'on par une augmentation
des tarifs
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que il
va falloir avancer que des
établissements sont dans le rouge depuis
depuis la crise kobina il ya eu un très
gros manque d'activité et une
augmentation des tarifs c'est un petit
peu la carotte 1 par la direction
c'est à dire qu'elles vont demander une
nouvelle fois encore plus au personnel
de faire encore plus d'activités pour
pouvoir renflouer les caisses et c'est
tout l'effet pervers de cette annonce de
sa lance aujourd'hui alors qu'on a des
soignants qui sont extrêmement fatiguée
usée et qui quittent l'hôpital donc on
se demande comment ça va se passer par
la suite
quand on vous entendez emmanuel macron
dire hier à cette eau dans son discours
il et je vais demander encore un effort
à nos soignants qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
c'est là c'est pour la même routine à on
nous demande encore et encore et encore
des efforts cc1 défini avec lui alors
fait c'est lui qui nous met la tête sous
l'eau ça fait ça fait des années qu'on
crie manque de moyens dans les hôpitaux
est aujourd'hui la politique de monsieur
macron à la garde son cap c'est à dire
des fermetures de vie il n'y a pas de
choc d'actrice d'attractivité qui était
qui a été prévu à la base quand on voit
aujourd'hui pour augmenter le
capacitaire on va encore faire appel à
nos étudiants infirmiers en europe
opératoire qui sont mis à disposition
des employeurs jusqu'à jusqu'au mois de
mai malheureusement c'est que des modes
dégradé qui est qu'ils nous proposent
aujourd'hui notamment pour les
réanimations les secteurs covin donc on
est toujours dans cette politique du
dégradé il ya rien de nouveau en tout
cas pour nous il a promis emmanuel
macron guerre de passer de 7 me lire de
réanimation a diminué
réanimation sauf que le 27 août dernier
il nous avait déjà promis 12 me lis ça
aussi comment vous réagissez dans les
rangs des hôpitaux on imagine que ça
doit être un petit peu compliqué
entendre ce genre de promesses bien sûr
ces voiles a cessé d annonce encore des
effets d'annoncé pour rassurer la
population mais aujourd'hui on sait et
on s'est complètement personnel on sait
pourquoi pas ouvrir des lits de
réanimation comme ça depuis un an donc
et qu'il faut des moyens supplémentaires
formés du père noël les seul moyen
qu'ils ont trouvé cette forme et des
collègues en des temps record un en jour
deux journées de formation pour aller
dans l'animation on sait que c'est
totalement impossible d'un agira pour
les collectifs ont envoyé au front
notamment les capacités on va récupérer
les collègues qui subissent la
déprogrammation dans les blocs
opératoires les infirmiers les
intéristes voilà c'est des solutions à y
perdre et monsieur macron sous le coup
des faits pour évoquer ces confinement
et de justifier souvent on nous a
beaucoup agité le chiffon terrible indue
du tri des patients que évidemment
personne ne souhaite certains médecins
pourtant nous disent que ce n'est pas
loin la dent dans les hôpitaux alors ya
évidemment beaucoup d'hôpitaux en france
mais comment ça se passe concrètement
chez vous par exemple sur le terrain il
ya une grosse disparité
quand on regarde la france nous par
exemple on est sur un plateau plutôt
moyen donc par rapport à octobre et
novembre où c'était une grosse crise
dans ma région
aujourd'hui on est sur des plots sur un
plateau moyens mais on a des collègues
qui nous font leur retour en terres
noires l'île de france dans le sud de la
france du côté de paisibles où ça
commence est largement la crise avec des
profs des déprogrammations massive
donc forcément après il y aura des choix
à faire puisque du côté de la chirurgie
on va des programmes et des gens il ya
une perte de chant qui s'articule autour
de ça c'est ça c'est net et c'est réel
dernière question rachid d'ivoire vient
d'entendre un christophe castaner tout à
l'heure tous vantent les mérites de la
proposition de la loi ségur de la santé
avec cette hausse de 2
euros sur le salaire des infirmiers est
ce que c'est une hausse réelle vous
l'avez constaté avec herman sur le
terrain dans les hôpitaux alors déjà je
voudrais faire un rappel très important
pour les médias qui parlent de hausse ou
de revalorisation alors il faut dire que
c'est un ajustement
ça fait plus de dix ans que nos salaires
sont gelés donc ne peut pas parler de
hausse
on sait juste mis à niveau on va dire à
un niveau moyen
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est des vrais
revalorisation de salaire c'est à dire
que certains corps de métiers notamment
des blocs opératoires soient payées à
leur juste valeur au niveau d'études etc
il ya des travaux qui sont en cours
notamment à khost ségur
mais aujourd'hui on voit que les
personnels qui sont qui sont concernés
ne sont pas conviés à ce genre de
réunion pour discuter notamment des
différents travaux
donc aujourd'hui c'est c'est un petit
peu comme aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé
à 100 glisse et le gouvernement c'est
tout de son côté ou alors choisi à la
limite ses interlocuteurs puisque les
interlocuteurs qui dérange
on va pas aller on va parler les
solliciter pour qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu simple dialogue social avec le
gouvernement et et ça nous a vons rien
de bon en tout cas pour la suite
merci rachid d'ego je rappelle que vous
êtes président du collectif inter bloc
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france